all right next question is from Rivi
rivey says what jobs are way more
difficult than people think that they
are I have two sets of ideas for this I
mean number one generally I think that
foodservice type jobs and service
industry type jobs are definitely more
difficult than they typically get credit
for both physically and sort of
emotionally psychologically being a
waiter or waitress it's not something
that I've ever done when I used to work
at a skating rink when I was in my teens
I did a little bit of food service but
it was basically standing behind a
counter serving people sodas and slices
of pizza it's not you know remembering
whoever made food is already a yeah sure
nothing nothing really too involved so
certainly I think anything in food
service whether you're in the kitchen
and you're standing the entire day
typically very very hot not the best
conditions cooking and having to keep
track mentally of all the orders if
you're out on the floor of the
restaurant waitressing or waitering
and having to deal with unruly customers
and people who come in with all sorts of
dietary demands and if anything if
anything goes even slightly astray they
want your head I think that those jobs
are really tough I also believe that
jobs where you work with children are
inherently very very difficult now that
doesn't mean people don't love it and
that people don't find it incredibly
rewarding obviously they do and they do
on both both counts but I think that
working with kids is exhausting in a way
that if you don't work with kids if you
get used to just hey I'm really mostly
working with adults and it's very easy
to communicate if you add on top of that
you that your job is with people that
have a much more limited understanding
of knowledge of language and of the
world I think that that's really tough
yeah and the unfortunate thing is that
both occupations you laid out they're
both food service workers and those who
work with children be it in social work
or in teaching yeah it's very low paid
out working with the mentally
handicapped I think is really really
tough and I know people that do in
different capacities and it is very very
difficult work I don't think that they
get credit they deserve for the
difficulty of their jobs blue-collar
jobs in general and I know that there
are people I work in a job where we're
not doing heavy lifting here right
coming in we're working on computers
were coming up with clever ways to
present political stories I don't deny
that I have built a very specific set of
skills that all I sound like Liam Neeson
Elvis and that come from you know the
education that I've gotten and and
running a business and it is mentally
taxing I don't deny that for for a
second but I also think that for all the
people working white so-called
white-collar jobs or information age
type jobs who say it's so easy in the
blue-collar world because yes it's
physically demanding but you have way
way less in the form of stressful mental
decisions that have to be made I think
you're drastically undercutting the
difficulty of a lot of those jobs any
other thoughts that you have on just
jobs that are tougher than people
generally give them anymore the coal
miners right true collar workers and
construction and yes any kind of you
know I I think the reality is that most
jobs have difficulties that unless you
are familiar at least with the industry
if not the job you probably don't
appreciate you probably don't and I mean
just to pick one airline pilot is often
seen as like very very glamorous and
you're jetting around to these different
places and you very often have at least
if you're doing like long-haul flights
for legacy carriers you you have a
couple days off between flights you
might only do two flights a week or
something like that
the number one the jet lag and the
constant messing with your body clock is
really really difficult and number two
there's quite a bit of emotional strain
or mental weight in knowing that even
small mistakes could cost the lives of
hundreds of people on the plane and
certainly potentially thousands of
people who are below and relate to the
families of all the people that are on
the plane I think that there's a lot to
that not to mention that particularly
with regional carriers they're really
not paid very well and sometimes you're
doing six to eight flights a day yeah I
think that's why it's annoying when
people brag about how how hard they work
yeah because you gotta people put
yourself in other people's shoes or
everybody's working everyone's working
hard well and not ever you can't put
yourself ahead of those be yeah there
are certainly people not working
Hart and Donald Trump knows a lot of
those people and many of them are about
to get much much wealthier as a result
of his tax bill